I've recently become obsessed with the
the the role that design plays in the
construction of our mind we're in the
construction of our sense of self and I
remember I was in cave town giving a
keynote for IBM and this guy that I met
called me hole computer scientist
brilliant guy who was a fan of my web
series shots of awe showed up for this
talk and we ended up connecting and
going and hanging out and spending the
day walking around the Botanical Gardens
of Cape Town in the middle of a storm on
this bridge that go over that went over
the canopy of trees so the total kind of
you couldn't ask for a better stage for
a sort of cerebral conversation and I
was talking to him about my desire to to
steer awareness again how do i transcend
what Michael Colin what Michael Pollan
calls the bin there's and done that's of
the addled mind how do I it elicits a
childlike sense of wonder how do I
control and steer subjectivity
ultimately my obsession and so he said
he said oh that's easy you know we do
that all the time with design it's
called ontological design I was what
until what
tell me again ontological design and I
was like what does that mean it has to
do with with the nature of beingness
itself ontology what it is to be what it
is to to inhabit a mind world a life
world the world hood and basically the
idea of ontological design is very
simple it basically says that design
affects us in a way that is much more
pervasive than we're normally privy to
the notion is that whether we're
conscious of it or not everything that
we design is designing us back we are
being actively designed by that which we
have designed this of course echoes
terence mckenna's idea that we become
what we behold or a Marshall McLuhan
snow ssin that first we build the tools
but then they build us you know or
Stephen Johnson when he says our
thoughts shape our spaces you know we
build cathedrals we architectural
dwellings and then those spaces return
the favour' those spaces build our
thoughts our thoughts build our spaces
the spaces return the favor
so my friend was talking about this
notion that ontological design implies
that there is this hermeneutic circle in
in this in the sense of mind mind
emerges and the feedback loops between
brains
tools and environments and there's a
meaning making circle the self emerges
like a like the arrow burrows like the
dragon that's eating its own tail right
or like Esther's hands where you have
the hand that is drawing the hand that
is drawing it so it's like this infinity
loop and that that's basically how the
way mind wear emerges you know who we
are that the feedback loop should be the
metaphor of our age right instead of the
DNA molecule it should be the feedback
loop there was a an essay written on a
on magazine recently about this notion
but again it's not just our genetics
that determine who we are it's the
feedback loops between self and world
and and this is the notion of
ontological design and I think the
takeaway being is that by harnessing
those feedback loops we can build better
mind where we can build systems we can
build cities cityscapes dwelling spaces
even the words we use to map our reality
can be improved recursively because
it'll feedback and then improve we are
better tools those little tools then
interface with us and create better
ideas and then we use those tools to
build new tools and then those new tools
interface with us and so on and so forth
until until novelty approaches infinity
and realities fly apart there's Diana
Slattery writes in her book xeno
linguistics but uh yeah so again it
should give us as humans a sense of
responsibility for authoring the
mindedness of the future you know the
minds of the future can be built it's a
kind of social engineering project
everything that we design should be
thought of as a building block as new
construction kits for our reality you
can imagine why my head exploded when I
was with this guy over the canopy on a
bridge in the Botanical Gardens of Cape
Town during a storm and the guy starts
telling me about ontological design
because I was witnessing ontological
design happening in that moment that's
staged that context in which we were
over the trees in the Botanical Gardens
was conditioning the nature of my
subjective experience as he was telling
me about this idea I was witnessing the
power of our creative and linguistic
choices to author my subjectivity even
the words we were using to describe to
map our experience were being fed
back into our experience and it's just a
reminder of the the sort of dizzying
freedom that we have to compose our
lives to compose our experience Timothy
Leary used to call this the vertigo of
freedom
it's crazy idea right but it's a nice I
find it I find it reassuring I find it
inspiring that we have we're we're the
music makers we are the dreamers of
dreams we have in the pen we get we get
to we get to be reality engineers
reality architects and I love that I
love that idea